12 32 67
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich denke
[Musik]
[Applaus]
normalerweise steht wir dann mit
weltstars auf der bühne
durch der weg bis nach oben war nicht
ganz leicht wenn ich vorne rein wenn es
auch weniger botschaft größte hat weil
der wagen ich glaube ich war nicht in
der körper muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen
klappt es mal ab und im dschungel steht
fest und weiß nicht woher ich das ja
eigentlich weniger theater was ich nicht
unbedingt da lag ausgelöst hat von
vornherein seit seiner kindheit hatte er
einen traum
tanzen ich heiße wir dann und bin tänzer
seit meiner kindheit wollte ich mit den
stars tanzen
geboren in malaysia lebt er heute in los
angeles und tanzt für die ganz großen im
showbusiness wie hier für christina
aguilera zur welt kam er in einem
flüchtlingslager
seine eltern waren aus vietnam geflohen
und schafften es schließlich in die
schweiz
[Musik]
die eltern verboten ihm das tanzen
anfänglich doch heute kann ihn nichts
mehr stoppen
in der schweiz ist wir dann als
choreograf und tanz experte bekannt
wird jetzt dirk war mir sehr gut
gefallen ich mein logisch der silo die
härtere arbeit machen was in los angeles
tritt er in videoclips von erstklassigen
popstars und in werbespots von
weltkonzernen auf
[Musik]
ich treffe den tänzer und choreographen
auf dem flughafen von kuala lumpur
er ist aus ll angekommen wo er seit
sechs jahren lebt seine mutter ist aus
basel angereist
wir begeben uns mit den beiden auf
spurensuche an den ort wo wir vor 39
jahren geboren wurde
aber die dinge
wie schwierig sich und die heißt das
immer munter flüsse vorheriger gut
das ist aber zunächst behalten
aufgewachsen ist wird in basel
nun möchte er herausfinden ob hier in
malaysia wo er sein erstes lebensjahr
verbracht hat vielleicht die wurzeln
seiner kraft und lebensfreude liegen
kuala terengganu an der ostküste
malaysias eine flugstunde von der
hauptstadt entfernt von hier fahren wir
mit dem taxi an den küstenabschnitt an
dem die familie von wird dank damals
angekommen ist
die geburtsgeschichte sehr traurige
geschichte das ist ein tragischer die
eltern die gern
nach hause muss ich jede information gab
es am 1
darüber rede war motto wissen was ich
sie schon
schockieren salami
beide eltern daheim im hafen von meran
shetty entdecken wir ein altes
fischerboot es gleich demjenigen mit dem
die familie aus vietnam geflohen ist
[Musik]
die mutter hatte zum zeitpunkt der
flucht bereits drei kleinkinder mit dem
vierten war sie hochschwanger
der vater ein hochsee kapitän saß am
steuer des schiffes verantwortlich für
146 flüchtlinge an bord nehmen zwei eine
eine hier in einige wird immer
[Musik]
die dauer dinge erzählt wird unter
welchen umständen sie das land verlassen
haben
die in vietnam gut situierte familie
floh vor den kommunisten welcher nach
dem krieg die macht im land übernommen
hatten
anderthalb millionen vietnamesen taten
es ihnen gleich
die meisten kamen übers meer und
erstmals vernahm die westliche welt vom
schicksal von bootsflüchtlingen wie sie
heute zu tausenden über das mittelmeer
gelangen sowie wird familie geführt vom
vater meiner familie frau und ihr baby
im buch und eine weitere 115 und 140
miteinander verantwortung stand das
extreme bedruckt abgedankt und der mann
darüber funktioniert einfach mal sagen
sie sie haben es ins haus abgeschlossen
sind so froh und es ist mir egal da man
das irgendwo gesehen hat sich dem zug
ich will sich jetzt als blick muss es
sein großes ist jedes dritte das podest
gesehen und wusste somit dame ins offene
meer in fahrt 232 alltag mit jährlicher
shipping bisschen länger diese zeit gar
nicht denken gar nicht etwa die sun
so eine schiffbänker mut für alle leute
kommen aber da grausamen jemand
sheffield einholen aber nachher viele
leute so in schiffweiler verkaufen leben
und vermögen legten die flüchtlinge in
die hände von schleppern das brot war
komplett überladen wir kaufen sein wie
affen hier unten wir sehr stinkt
wird du kannst dir nicht vorstellen was
wir durchgemacht haben und dass du unter
solchen umständen zur welt gekommen bist
du hast es mir auch schon erzählt
wenn du gewusst hat ist worauf du dich
einlässt hättest du die flucht dennoch
angetreten
erst als wir im schiff waren erkannten
wir dass es kein zurück gab vater hat
auch einen schock gekriegt ein kleines
überfülltes schiff und er trägt die
verantwortung für über 100 menschen
seine verantwortung wahr es das schiff
übers meer zu steuern
er war mutig vom fischerboot wechseln
wir auf ein schnellboot das uns zu als
geburtsstätte bringen soll
an dieser küste sind sie damals
angekommen hinter ihnen der offenen
ozean mit lauernden piratenbanden vor
ihnen ein land überfordert vom ansturm
tausender flüchtlinge zuerst trieb die
örtliche polizei mit einem
maschinengewehr auch unsere flüchtlinge
zurück aufs offene meer
nur dank der hilfe europäischer
journalisten konnten sie schließlich das
festland erreichen also unbekannt also
und aber irgendwie doch bekannt
ericsson habe keine erinnerung es ist
seltsam vertraut seine familie gehört zu
den 6.000 vietnam flüchtlingen welche
die schweiz ende der siebziger jahre aus
humanitären gründen aufgenommen hat
am horizont taucht die insel pulau
wiederum auf
[Musik]
die insel ist unbewohnt 1978 bestimmte
der malaysische statt sie zu flüchtlings
setzte
[Musik]
ihr comeback
es sind bilder die damals weltweit
erschütterung ausgelöst haben
heute ist die insel ein mahnmal für die
flüchtlingskatastrophe
[Musik]
als die familie im november 1978 hier
ankam lebten bereits über 20.000
flüchtlinge auf pulau wieder ein halbes
jahr später 40.000 deswegen ruft ihn
sind klappt im quartier de france sind
druck stand und hofft dass ich mich
recht verwarnt
so sind
gerade mal ein zehntel der insel hvar
bewohnbar bei ihrer ankunft erhielten
die flüchtlinge eine machete um sich im
dschungel einzurichten zu unterziehen
seine mission eric station ist sei im
news station neuigkeiten gedenktafeln an
einem symbolischen schiff sind stumme
zeugen persönlicher schicksale hier
angekommen zu sein bedeutet er noch
lange nicht das ende des
überlebenskampfes in dem motorwagen
treter verloren und war gegen die hand
liegt aber weiter festgefahren
warum braucht
hoffnung glaube gute nacht haben
funktionäre der funktion wird soll
räucherstäbchen anzünden damit bruder
ihnen hilft ihren lagerplatz zu finden
damals konnte sich die familie keine
opfergaben leisten
heute möchte sich die mutter bei butter
bedanken dass er sie vor dem schlimmsten
bewahrt und sie bis in die schweiz
geführt hat
denn an da ja fast nichts zeigt mehr von
der damaligen zeit vom leben das die
flüchtlingsfamilie im dschungel geführt
hat notdürftige behausung wenig essen
kaum medizinische versorgung keine
zukunft ein schweres leben
seine denn keine antwort gab jeden tag
ich denke bringen alle ging der im
wasser
sie wollten sich und ihre kinder
ertrinken
wenn ich getroffen dem dennoch leben das
wäre für kinder
und wenn ging jedoch knapp neben das
wäre ja es ist ein projekt mit alisa
liste aber wenn sie überleben wird
schwierig für das was überlebt sterben
oder weiterleben alle oder keiner
dieses motto hilft die familie wie ein
unsichtbares band zusammen
im gegensatz zu vielen anderen haben sie
es geschafft der hölle zu entrinnen
dafür sind sie bis heute dankbar
plötzlich entdeckt die mutter im dichten
urwald etwas das sie an ihr lager
erinnert und viele kollegen machen und
dann wohnen hier in der nähe muss ihr
platz gewesen sein
ein lehrgang deine belecke
[Musik]
die bühne ist unter uns hessische große
baum
die verwahrung center haben sich ihre
salsa bundes machen wundert ja ich
glaube dass ich hier da waren ja keine
einem monat nachher geworden wer mehr
ich bin krank und keine mir vor wir
danken unseren etat wird sieht nur wenig
gesagt mit meinem mann warum gott geben
so kleben früher und immer so hängen
jeden tag nur weinen bringen unten leute
helfen reichen locker 13 leute hocken
eine wenn verwertbare und drei tage
tupfer und nacken keine nerven und
machen eine hier werden an fusion ja ich
bin sehr sehr froh und der bringt in
oben
die die flasche hätte ihm gefunden
im meer gefunden und hätten die ketchup
flasche unterricht militärische shopper
flash access loch dritter dann hätte
snooki form ihrer älteren schwester
der tritt steckt keine kleider kaum
entwickelt wurde im helm von ihrem vater
und drei tage später hat eine frau -
eine rose geschenkt und hält sie so
auseinander geschnitten und mehr ist als
rose gleich knallt das neue hobby von
mir sagt was ist ein anderer zeuge hat
und das hat sie fotos gemacht und das
deshalb töten und seine schule decke wo
sie uns gerne der heckenschnitt
ausgestellt und untersagte das gemacht
habe
und da ich bin wirklich letzte
geschichte kann was passiert ist oder
auf zugang und warum welches die
alltagsprobleme oder karrieren karriere
problem und sonst so klein nicht das ist
so nicht also nichts bedeutet im
vergleich zu das zusammen warum und
danach der raistinger eltern dankbar für
sie schon ausgemacht dass das teil der
familiengeschichte die hier sind sind
dir da ausschnitt und die wartung sich
nicht und ich habe es kleine enttäuscht
dass mir das alter grundsatz habe
gewarnt dass kinder glücklich sind
wieder zurück in kuala terengganu
[Musik]
und
am strand muss sich an das flüchtlings
elend der gegenwart denken und daran wie
wenig wir aus der geschichte lernen
immerhin halbwegs geschichte einen guten
verlauf genommen
unglaubliche freiheit schenkt ist die
flucht aus knoten sich selber freiheit
chance die heckscheibe und das machen
was ich will und kondition war ein
anders zusammen vietnam leben und
30 auch gefangene sie im kopf gefallen
sie von sozialem oder angefangen sie
verpflichten
und ich glaube das ganze werk gemacht
hand in hand mit mehr kinder in unserem
kopf gefallen sind
ja
die dachschrägen
[Musik]
module